they marched towards the match together
fans from both Donetsk and Kiev led by
the hardcore ultras but followed by a
mixed crowd chanting pro Ukraine and
anti-putin slogans showing their
defiance of Russia with the country's
prices on everyone's mind they had a
strong message for the separatists in
the east the unity that we are together
right now and we are for Ukraine and to
show that Ukraine is together today fans
came from all over the country to watch
this final supporters from Donetsk and
Kiev or once bitter rivals and often
clashed in the past but not today the
political situation has brought them
closer together domino's nosh on a
stranger but i think the mood will be
friendly because everyone is cheering
for ukraine there won't be any conflict
here we one country why should the fans
have to fight each other there's no
sense in that I don't think it's right
at the wood planer spectators were only
given the green light to be here a day
before the game given the political
rivalries between Kiev and Donetsk this
game almost didn't happen for security
reasons authorities initially didn't
want to allow any fans in the stadium
they had a last-minute change of heart
the fans are here and they say they
United supporters from Kiev were
thrilled with their side's 2-1 win the
game is fantastic and they have no words
okay I'm
glad to the campus at genomic rhian
jones and i was the best this was an
important win not just for dynamo kyiv
but for two cities with opposing views
and polarized politics the hope is that
if football can bring them together
maybe the politicians could do the same